bonsoir à tous édition spéciale de votre
19 ans en bourgogne au lendemain du
premier tour des élections
départementales avec elle a besoin pour
détailler les principaux résultats dans
nos quatre départements
lilian melet pour analyser la
progression du vote front national en
bourgogne
eric sicaud pour décrypter le cas
particulier de la saône et loire
commençons donc par ce département où la
majorité de gauche est menacée à l'image
de rémi chaintron le président
socialiste sortant dans le canton de
louhans 1500 voix de retard par rapport
à la droite arrivée largement en tête
une nouvelle campagne commence à la
recherche du vote des abstentionnistes
damien bouthillier et romy la chute le
marché de louhans avec sa centaine de
commerçants et ses milliers de
promeneurs et acheteurs
c'est un lieu incontournable de la vie
bressane mais surprise en ce lundi matin
d'entre deux tours des élections
départementales
il n'y a pas de serrage de mains des
candidats qualifiés pour le second tour
les postes surprise là il se repose
maintenant ils ont ils ont fait ce qu'il
fallait quoi ils sont pas réveillés ils
ont passé la nuit sont fatigués tout
simplement il ya des comptes en plus des
mécontentements fallait pourtant les
candidats sont bien en campagne mais
aujourd'hui ils ne font pas de terrain à
l'instar de l'ump on laisse les gens
parler faire le bilan lui même voilà on
va pas aller déranger
on va sûrement essayer d'aller voir
certains abstentionnistes
parce que même si ici une belle
mobilisation est encore voilà des gens
qui sont pas le voter et rappeler c'est
un enjeu local même si un message fort
au niveau national qui était lancée il
faut rappeler que les élections
départementales c'est des enjeux locaux
donc les gens choisissent leurs
représentants quant à rémi chaintron il
est aux abonnés absents
il s'est isolé des caméras et des médias
pour écrire la profession de foi de son
binôme mais dès hier soir il tirer les
enseignements du premier tour je crois
qu'effectivement on paye aussi
certaine défiance vis-à-vis du parti
socialiste je n'ai jamais caché mon
étiquette j'ai toujours ma carte et je
la garderais j'ai toujours dit que
j'étais plus socialiste que beaucoup
d'autres et donc c'est vrai que ça va
être c'est un 2e tour compliqué mais
vous savez en politique on a l'habitude
des 2e tour compliqué donc on va tout
faire pour rattraper le retard
même si c'est vrai qu'il est important
ainsi à gauche la pilule a du mal à
passer
car même à montrer où sa colistière
sabine schaeffer et mr le ps est battu
d'autres résultats en saône-et-loire
al'inverse de louhans elsa la gauche
résiste à cluny mais cluny où le tandem
jean luc fonteray lisabeth le mot non le
seul binôme socialiste élu en bourgogne
au premier tour
affaire réglée aussi pour le canton de
chauffailles la candidate divers droite
marie christine bignon est réélu à
binôme de droite élu également à
charolles ou pierre berthier josiane
corneloup rafle la mise avec 51% des
voix dans le canton de saint vallier le
binôme du front de gauche est le seul à
se maintenir au second tour et dia dont
il ira donc un divers gauche gauche
dimanche prochain à digoin digoin la
gauche est malmené le tandem philomène
baccot jean-claude drapier est en
ballottage défavorable
idem à châlons 2 où l'on se dirige vers
un affrontement droite gauche au
deuxième tour
même situation dans le canton de
montceau les mines la gauche en grand
danger à face à la droite enfin un
dernier résultat arnaud pour le
département soit noir celui de la
chapelle de guinchay à la droite victime
de ses divisions arrive deuxième
derrière le front national
alors éric cecos est l'une des
principales questions de cet entre deux
tours la saône-et-loire peut-elle
basculer à droite
et la réponse est oui même s'il reste de
nombreuses incertitudes dans ce
département la gauche résiste en effet
en saône et loire on l'a vu elle recule
nettement 1 par rapport à 2011 mais
globalement elle reste en tête avec un
total de 38,5 % des voix devant le bloc
de droite qui la talonne à 37,6 et
l'extrême droite qui est plus faible
qu'ailleurs à 23,5
mais cette première place ne signifie
pas pour autant qu'elle va conserver le
département
les 26 cantons qui restent à pourvoir
sont autant d'élections différentes et
on l'a vu la gauche est en mauvaise
posture dans le canton même du président
sortant à louhans
mais aussi à autun 1h allant de à digoin
et à montceau de son côté la droite
hormis ces cantons qu'elle peut prendre
à la gauche par être imbattable sur
givry mâcon et paray ou encore tournus
sans compter bien sûr charolles et
chauffailles où elle a déjà deux nuls
dynamique de droite n'est pas très forte
non elle progresse très peu par rapport
à 2011 trois points seulement alors que
le contexte lui est très favorable
voilà donc qui laisse encore de l'espoir
à la gauche qui est notamment en
ballotage plutôt favorable dans sept des
huits triangulaire et elle est à peu
près certaine de sauver quelques places
fortes comme au creusot à autun 2 à
gueugnon où évidemment à saint vallier
puisqu'il n'y a plus ici que deux
binômes du front de gauche et du parti
socialiste sur papier en fait on peut
attribuer une parfaite égalité entre les
deux camps avec des situations
extrêmement serrée dans beaucoup
d'endroits à gergy cuiseaux chalon 3 ou
encore pierre de bresse pour ne citer
qu'eux en fait si les résultats du
deuxième tour reste conforme aux
premiers la majorité pour n'est pourrait
n'être que de deux sièges
d'un côté comme de l'autre autant dire
qu'à droite comme à gauche les candidats
vont devoir aller chercher les électeurs
avec les dents et si possible convaincre
les abstentionnistes du premier tour de
faire la différence
merci eric dans 27 départements français
le front national arrive promis en
nombre de voix c'est le cas dans l'yonne
et dans la nièvre chez nous dans le
canton de pont sur yonne le binôme fn
devance même la droite de 10 points
le conseiller sortant ps troisième
déclaré hier vouloir se maintenir
rien n'est moins sûr basis djaouti
cédric le poids de 20 la chasse aux
abstentionnistes julien oudoul a beau
être arrivé en tête au premier tour le
candidat front national est déjà reparti
en campagne comme ici sur cette petite
commune rurale du nord de l'yonne
dimanche prochain le binôme frontiste
aura face à lui droite et gauche une
triangulaire a priori favorable mais il
refuse d'entrer dans ces considérations
je regarde pas ça de manière
politicienne en fait moi j'essaie de
convaincre tout le monde
nous sommes arrivés en tête c'est un bon
signal je vais essayer mobiliser les
électeurs pour se porter pour se
rassembler autour de ma candidature qui
comme je le répète est la seule pour
améliorer leur quotidien
les troupes aller chercher les
abstentionnistes grégory dorte passera
une bonne partie de la journée
pendu au téléphone arrivé deuxième le
candidat divers droite en appellent
désormais au front républicain pour
faire barrage au fn il faut que tout le
monde se mobilise et compris dominique
baud pour je pense pour s'abstenir
se désister au deuxième tour pour avoir
une chance que les forces républicaines
l'emportant directement visée donc le
binôme socialiste dominique bourreau en
tête le conseiller général sortant s'est
qualifié de justesse pour le second tour
consciente du danger d'une victoire
frontiste
il dit encore réfléchir à une éventuelle
retraite c'est un vrai risque qui on
voit le nombre de voix du front national
le front national qui voilà qui arrive
largement en tête et c'est vrai alors
c'est une élection à risque il faut le
reconnaître
sauf ultime coup de théâtre le binôme
socialiste devrait donc s'effacer et les
électeurs avoir le choix entre le front
national où la droite classique dimanche
prochain autre cas de figure auxerre 2
le canton partie nord de la ville avec
et communes d'appoigny et monéteau
auxerre fief de la gauche mais elle est
partie divisée dans ces élections
et là elle n'a pas eu le choix éliminé
dès hier nathalie baffert et kloten
dans le canton de serre de se jouer un
duel entre deux sortants l'un ump
l'autre ps et c'est le socialiste
jacques aux lots qui en sort grand père
dont il est éliminé dès le premier tour
comme un symbole de la perte d'influencé
du ps dans l'auxerrois contexte national
évidemment puisqu'il n'y a pas inclus
dans l'yonne qu'on trouve une poussée du
fn et la droite unie l'ump ont su se
rassembler ce que la gauche n'a pas su
faire je pense que l'extrême gauche a
une grosse part de responsabilité dans
le résultat du premier tour
c'est donc robert bideau le sortant ump
qui affrontera au second tour le front
national depuis 2012 le maire de
monéteau a vu grandir la désaffection
des habitants des communes périurbaines
vis-à-vis du ps aujourd'hui
plus rien pour la gauche et puis on se
partage les voies avec le front national
c'est quand même très ce qui veut dire
ce qui correspond bien
je dirais à ce que la population se
désengage du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui le candidat ump pourra en
tout cas compter sur le soutien de son
ex adversaire socialiste le candidat
battu jacquot gelos a lancé ce matin un
appel à faire barrage au front national
et justement le front national est lui
déjà reparti en campagne contre le front
républicain
le seul programme de nos adversaires que
ce soit le ps ou l'ump c'est lutter
contre le front national lutter contre
le front national lutter contre le front
national
je ne vois pas nos opposants politiques
parler de programme
ils sont que dans l'opposition front
national donc j'appelle quelques parle
aussi les abstentionnistes à se déplacer
beauté est aussi à les sanctionner et à
voter pour un changement de politique un
changement d'hommes politiques dans les
trois autres cantons auxerrois
le ps sera présent au second tour mais
il a réalisé des scores très en retrait
par rapport à 2008 et 2011
certains à droite y voient déjà le signe
d'un début de reconquête de la capitale
de l'yonne à noter toujours dans lionel
face aux autres quand on part marqué par
la montée du parti de marine le pen ont
une vague bleu marine a déferlé surles
une illustration de ce phénomène avec
trois cantons où le front national a des
chances de gagner à d'abord le fn
pourrait remporter charny si l'électorat
de gauche éliminée ne se déplace pas aux
urnes situation similaire à migennes
avec un duel l'ump extrême droite au
deuxième tour le parti frontiste en
ballottage favorable également dans le
canton de brienon sur armançon plusieurs
duels entre le fn et la droite
exemple à joux la ville où le président
sortant du conseil général dudit à andré
villiers arrive en tête devant le tandem
frontiste à droite le sénateur ump jean
baptiste lemoyne fait mieux puisqu'il
est le seul élu dès le premier tour dans
le département avec sa colistière
delphine grémy c'est dans le canton de
gastines et en bourgogne et de ce fait
il prend l'ascendant dans la course à la
présidence du département
pour finir 1re rue de soirée pour la
gauche dans l'yonne même dans son
bastion d'avalon houleux
au ps se classe troisième et il se
retrouve engagé dans une triangulaire à
haut risque au deuxième tour la nièvre à
présent la le front national est en
mesure de se maintient dans 14 des 17
cantons dont celui de nevers 2 celui de
l'est et du sud de la ville il est
arrivé en tête avec 76 voix d'avancé sur
le ps reste à faut savoir pour qui ils
vont voter les électeurs des trois
autres binômes en course il hier
richesse guillon et cécile claveau vous
regarderez le journal en première page
et deuxième page vous reconnaitre le
front national à vous regarderez en
entendant front national l'électeur
tourner les talons
il n'est pas d'accord avec ses idées et
pourtant elles sont potentiellement
majoritaire dans le canton hier soir le
binôme fn emmenée par christophe
gaillard est arrivé partout en tête sur
nevers 2 même ici à magny cours
il y aura cet effet booster on arrive
partout en tête partout en tête on
arrive dans les quatre villes de notre
canton et demain ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que enfin les habitants de ce
canton peuvent donner leur voix au front
national pour que le front national
siège réellement conseil départemental
très sincèrement nous pouvons le front
national peut arracher ce canton demain
ce canton qui fut celui de pierre
bérégovoy déjà connu en 2011 un duel ps
fn
delphine fleury la conseillère
socialiste sortante n'est d'ailleurs pas
surprise du résultat d'hier
la déception vient surtout du fait que
le front national soit devant oui on s'y
attendait il ya le contexte national qui
a beaucoup joué effectivement et puis le
fait que ce soit un canton recomposer un
nouveau territoire on a une partie très
rurale et on se rend compte à l'analyse
des résultats que les parties très
rurale ont voté plus massivement en tout
cas pas en notre faveur
néanmoins on n'est qu'à 76 voix d'écart
c'est pas non plus un raz-de-marée
ce matin au café le quadri nommé feng
savourer sa petite avance sur la gauche
l'effet marine le pen sans doute mais
pas seulement
localement je décline les propositions
nationales je les adapte au contexte
local et il ya vraiment contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait imaginer ce qu'on nous
dit de temps en temps il ya réellement
un travail de fond adapté ici à notre
canton
ça n'est pas vrai c'est un mensonge
voilà ils ont des propositions
nationales
il s'agit pas d'un scrutin national il
s'agit d'un scrutin local départemental
il faut agir pour ce département
continuer de le faire comme on l'a fait
jusqu'à maintenant
dimanche le ps devrait pouvoir compter
sur les voix du front de gauche
mais que fera la droite est éliminée au
premier tour et surtout les
abstentionnistes hier six électeurs sur
dix ne sont pas allés voter sur le
canton de nevers de duel gauche fn
oscille toujours dans la nièvre avec un
grand écart à corbigny
ouais c'est une terre historique de la
gauche qui pourrait passer de justesse
l'ump le fn s'est invitée au second tour
pour une triangulaire surprise autres
territoires où le fn joue les
trouble-fête clamecy la gauche est
éliminé duel droite extrême droite
dimanche prochain
dans la nièvre le fn est présent au
deuxième tour dans 14 des 17 cantons
parmi les exceptions nevers 1 où il n'y
a aucun candidate marine le pen en lice
dans ce canton là c'est le ps qui s'est
placée en tête à la sortie des urnes la
gauche qui reste solide à château chinon
l'ancien fief de françois mitterrand
patrice joly le président sortant se
dirige vers une réélection tranquille
enfin le front de gauche toujours entrer
à varennes-vauzelles associés au ps il
réalise son meilleur score dans le
département avec 36% des voix lilian
melet sur cette forte poussée du front
national va-t-il ou petit il l'a plutôt
obtenir des sièges dans nos conseils
départementaux
si on ne regarde que les chiffres le
front national dans cette élection c'est
presque 27% des voix en moyenne dans la
région quasiment le même pourcentage
cause européenne une présence au
deuxième tour dans soixante trois
cantons sur 90 avec au total 155 mille
trois cent trente neuf voix mais le
paradoxe c'est que ses 155 mille voix
pourrait ne leur donnez aucun élu dans
la configuration la plus défavorable et
une poignée seulement en hypothèse haute
pourquoi
en simplifiant à l'extrême on peut dire
parce que le front national n'a pas
beaucoup d'amis etc au deuxième tour il
faut des amis parce qu'il faut réunir
de plus on est dans le contexte national
d'un vote sanction contre la gauche
c'est donc la gauche qui est fréquemment
éliminé du deuxième tour et le front
national n'a pas beaucoup d'amis de ce
côté là prenons un exemple
saint-apollinaire en côte d'or le fn
talonne la droite mais 4500 voix de la
gauche et d'une liste droite modem sont
à redistribuer et gauche et modem feront
barrage au fn mais il ya parfois des
circonstances plus favorables
oui on peut relever de plusieurs types
par exemple pierre de bresse en saône et
loire trois binômes au premier tour
trois binômes qualifié pour le deuxième
tour dans un mouchoir de poche
aucun renfort c'est la dynamique de
chacun qui va jouer
autre situation dans l'yonne saint
florentin ou encore sens de dans ces
deux cas comme dans quelques autres le
front national vire en tête il a l'élan
et on sait que souvent les deuxièmes
tours amplifie les premiers on peut y
rajouter quelques interrogations sur une
érosion du réflexe de front républicain
chez les électeurs de gauche surtout
depuis le retour aux affaires de nicolas
sarkozy et puis il ya le cadre de pont
sur yonne avec le binôme ps qualifié en
troisième position mais pouvant compter
dans l'absolu sur des réserves du front
de gauche
s'il se retire il fera barrage au fn
s'il se maintient le front national
pourrait en profiter et transformer
l'essai de ses 38 % du premier tour
d'après nos informations ce soir c'est
l'hypothèse du retrait qui tiendrait la
corde mais rien n'est encore annoncée en
résumé vous l'avez compris c'est dans
l'yonne que le front national a fait son
plus grand score et c'est là qu'il a le
plus de chance de rentrer au conseil
départemental mais sans aucune certitude
merci millions il nous reste à nous
intéresser à la côte d'or avec un canton
où là aussi le front national est arrivé
en tête celui de brazey-en-plaine avec
les villes de seurre et de saint jean de
losne l'union de la droite et la
conseillère sortante
emmanuelle coint est deuxième le binôme
de la gauche est arrivée troisième il
annonçait tout à l'heure qu'il se
retirait christophe taris et iphone
faveur il était au centre des attentions
de fusil au soir arrivée très nettement
en troisième position alain becquet le
maire de seurre candidat de la gauche
pouvait se maintenir mais après une
longue réflexion il a décidé de jeter
l'épongé combats perdus mais pour
l'heure pas question de donner de
consigne de vote
je vais prendre part dans cette campagne
électorale deuxième tour nous n'avait on
avait un projet de territoire
donc aujourd'hui je n'ai pas retrouvé
dans le programme du front national
puisqu'il ya rien bien sûr sanaa
programme national ni malheureusement
dans le programme de la droite
un projet de territoire donc je vais
voir si effectivement ils changent leur
fusil d'épaulé
dans ce deuxième tour et qu'ils
intègrent certaines de nos idées qui
peuvent être éventuellement reprises un
désistement qui devrait profiter à lyon
de la droite arrivé deuxième avec moins
de 300 voix de retard
emmanuelle coint salue cette décision
difficile à prendre de son adversaire
mais refuse de modifier son programme
comment voulez vous que nous fassions
match franchement nous parlons de
solidarité humaine nous parlons de
solidarité de territoire
d'accompagnement des communes et des
projets de l'intercommunalité
je pense que ils peuvent se retrouver
dans ces dans ces actes là quant au
front national il est arrivé en première
position avec près de 40% des suffrages
et le parti frontiste est devant dans 22
des 38 communes du canton
il compte bien surfer sur cette
dynamique aujourd'hui on a quand même
deux mille six cents voix on à 2600
électeurs de livrer électeurs front
national et quoi qu'il arrive même si on
même si serré de très dur mais on va
amplifier la campagne aller chercher de
nouveaux fonds national parce qu'on sait
très bien que même s'il sait des sites
légaux n'appartiennent à personne
et pourquoi les électeurs du ps pour le
tmb le report des 1853 voix de la gauche
s'annonce donc dès 6 ans dans le canton
de talent dont font partie les communes
de plombières les dijon ou de sombernon
la division de la droite a bénéficié au
binôme de gauche
il devance celui du conseiller ump
sortant gilbert menut une triangulaire
sera donc que proposer aux électeurs
dimanche prochain la liste divers droite
perdante n'a pas encore donné de
consigne de vote pour le deuxième tour
reportage de pauline handy bag isabelle
rivière parti divisé à talons la droite
en paye les pots cassés
au lendemain du premier tour à l'abri
des regards gilbert menut le candidat
ump qui arrive deuxième derrière le ps
attend avec impatience les consignes de
vote de la liste dissidente pour le
deuxième tour alan lamy a obtenu 18% des
vous
à sa prise de position sera décisive
tout reste possible
il est vrai que une prise de position va
dire claire et bien en effet permettrait
une campagne plus plus sereine et des
choix plus facile pour pour les
électeurs concernés
de son côté philippe loza le candidat
front national n'attend rien de ce
report de voix le fn n'a que 7 voix de
retard sur l'ump et récolte 24,9 pour
cent des suffrages au premier tour un
score historique sur ce territoire
monsieur lamy aujourd'hui ses conseils
de vote
le reste finalement ne m'intéresse peu
ou prou je dirais voilà moi je ne
demande rien à personne
et finalement le front national on le
sait on est seul il n'y a pas de limite
de nanars des simplement les frontistes
on se cache pas d'ailleurs vous avez vu
on est le seul parti à s'afficher en
côte d'or un front national le candidat
sortant ps paul robinat et son binôme
ont finalement créé la surprise en se
maintenant en tête sur ce canton avec
31,5 pour cent des voix la division de
la droite a joué en leur faveur et la
triangulaire au deuxième tour ne leur
fait pas peur
on est relativement confiant parce que
précisément nous avons fait une campagne
de proximité
on va continuer toute la semaine aller à
la rencontre des habitants du canton
on a confiance en eux on a confiance en
nous
réellement on sait que ça va être un
petit peu difficile mais on y croit
ce scrutin reste l'un des plus
incertains dans le département que
feront les électeurs d'alain l'ami les
abstentionnistes seront ils au rendez
vous
rien n'est encore joué sur ce canton au
profil très particulier
le tour d'horizon de la côte d'or avec
un binôme élu au premier tour elsa et le
canton de châtillon sur seine est le
seul à avoir un tandem ait lieu dès le
premier tour valérie bouchard le maire
ump hubert brigand l emporte vous le
voyez avec plus de 52% des suffrages le
front national qui gagne du terrain dans
le département de la côte d'or on l'a vu
tout à l'heure avec brazey-en-plaine
c'est le cas aussi à aussonne où il
atteint même
score de 37 % des voix éliminant les
tandems ps et modem l'extrême droite
devant aussi dans le fief de la gauche
chenôve avec un duel qui s'annonce très
serré au second tour la gauche elle est
bien elle résiste plutôt bien dans la
capitale régionale en ballottage plus ou
moins favorable dans cinq des cantons
dijonnais notamment sur dijon ii le
maire alain millot et sa première
adjointe nathalie koenders sont pris une
belle avance face à la droite à
semur-en-auxois large avantage pour le
président hu dei sortant françois
sauvadet et il est contraint un deuxième
tour face à l'extrême droite mais il
devrait logiquement conserver son
fauteuil à la droite de françois
sauvadet qui étend son influence dans le
canton de montbard marc frot et laurence
porte sont en ballottage favorable face
aux radicaux de gauche marion mon
goichon et patrick molinoz merci éleva
ces résultats et bien d'autres également
à retrouver sur notre site internet
france3 point fr la synthèse nationale
dans un instant dans le journal de
carole gaessler nous irons dans le nord
qui pourrait basculer à droite en haute
garonne où le ps se maintient et
également dans l'aisne et dans le
vaucluse où le parti de marine le pen le
front national espère obtenir des sièges
prochain point départemental en
bourgogne dans le grand soir 3 vers
23h30
et puis l'info régionale demain c'est
dès 9h50 dans bourgogne franche comté
matin avec muriel rousselin le programme
tout de suite
bonne soirée sur france 3
retrouvez le dise